I've spoken to you before about
different ways in which the world really
has been laughing at us for a long time
since Donald Trump became president they
laughed when we elected a president who
thinks climate change is a Chinese hoax
they laughed that we elected a president
who has no idea how economics or
currency or trade or medicine or the
Constitution or the law or public
transit or any of it works
and they were laughing at us early
during the corona virus pandemic and
even as recently as a couple of weeks
ago many countries were laughing at us I
showed you about ten days ago
articles from all over the world the
Netherlands South Africa Peru everywhere
ridiculing our moronic president for his
comments about bleach injections and uh
the the other things he said during that
press briefing but they're not really
laughing anymore now it has gone from
laughter to concern to actual pity the
emails I have gotten over the last few
days from our international viewers
people that used to be poking fun at
Trump's idiotic claims about vaccines
and the virus they now write to me and
say David we feel sorry for you that you
are dealing with this in the United
States we feel sorry that you are in a
situation where no matter what you do
even if you do the right things even if
you have the best intentions and the
accurate understanding of what it is
that's going on and what it is that's
necessary to deal with this virus we
feel sorry for you because your federal
government has failed they are
incompetent
there is no plan there is just a series
of Lies and disinformation and confusion
and bogus talking points and there are
even Republicans who are willing to tell
the truth they are increasingly agreeing
this is just some Republicans of course
most of them are actually behind Donald
Trump check out Republican strategist
Steve Schmidt explaining it again this
is a lifelong Republican strategies take
a take a look Donald Trump has been the
worst president this country has ever
had and I don't say that hyper
yes um but he is a consequential present
and he has brought this country in three
short years to a place of weakness that
is simply unimaginable if you were
pondering where we are today from the
day where Barack Obama left office and
there were a lot of us on that day who
were deeply skeptical and very worried
about what a trump presidency would be
but this is a moment of unparalleled
national humiliation of weakness when
you listen to the president these are
the musings of an imbecile
an idiot and they don't use those words
the name-call I used them because
they're the precise words in the English
language to describe his behavior his
comportment his actions we've never seen
a level of incompetence a level of
ineptitude so staggering on a daily
basis by anybody in the history of the
country who's ever been charged with
substantial responsibilities Steve
Schmidt Schmidt is sadly absolutely
right the presidency is deadly and as
more and more countries open up it is us
people in the United States who won't be
allowed to fly into other countries
because we're a mess here as other
countries are actually dealing with the
problem as Trump talks about a
super-duper missile we'll get to that
later that's actually a phrase that he
used his son goes on TV and says it's
all going to disappear on election day
because it's merely a fake political
scandal by Democrats as that goes on
here the world is taking pity on us for
our failed leadership
I was trying over the weekend to think
of an analogy to try to apply to this
because there are people who are
analyzing this administration as if it
were a normal administration you have
these people some of them are so-called
enlightened centrists who pretend to see
both sides and find things they like and
Trump and things that they dislike
you can't evaluate this president like
you can other presidents here's an
analogy I thought of that I'm
workshopping and I want to try out on
you when someone says about Trump well
you know he has an unusual way of
talking about the issues but he's right
on deregulation and he's right on trade
but maybe he's not the best guy on
coronavirus imagine okay this is the
analogy imagine I was playing in a chess
tournament and I show up and I replace
all the Queen the pawns on the board
with Queens that I take out of my pocket
before the game starts that's insane and
it's simultaneously making a mockery of
the tournament it's also cheating
I'm also either an idiot or a bad person
for doing it imagine that a chess
commentator sees me take eight Queens
out of my pocket and put them on the
board instead of the pawns and says you
know David's strategy is unusual but
it's certainly an aggressive way to play
the game
well what no that doesn't make sense
yeah I mean some players use the Spanish
opening and others take Queens out of
their pocket and replace the pawns we're
not talking about the same thing here so
when these enlightened centrists and
pragmatic conservatives and whoever else
when they pretend to do an analysis of
Donald Trump's presidency as if it were
even remotely normal they're failing the
sniff test on principle but there's
another issue here with very few
exceptions in the Republican Party they
are mostly just enabling this there are
a few Republicans who have taken a stand
and are saying this can't happen right
you've got people like Mitt Romney who's
a current senator from Utah Republican
you have George Conway a lifelong
Republican Steve Schmidt lifelong
Republican strategist there are a few
other Republicans I can't name them all
who have not softened their view on
Trump and they are straight-up saying
this is not acceptable this is not
normal this can't be dealt with in
normal terms because normal terms don't
apply I'm not talking about them but for
the most part Republicans in Congress in
the House and Senate have enabled this
most Republican governors have enabled
this so Trump is not
alone to blame here we have to blame the
63 million Americans that voted for
Donald Trump yes they are to blame it
doesn't matter whether you call them bad
people or stupid or it they are to blame
their actions are to blame for what we
are dealing with right now of course
Trump is to blame but the Republican
Party that mostly continues to enable
him that even before the impeachment
trial had already decided were voting to
acquit Donald Trump on impeachment
charges they have to be held accountable
as well we have the opportunity to hold
every single one of the Republicans in a
house accountable in November we have an
opportunity to hold the Republicans that
are up for re-election in the Senate in
November which is of the 34 up for
re-election I forget the exact number of
Republicans but a number of Republicans
are up for re-election in November they
have to be held accountable as well this
episode is sponsored by blue Chu one of
the things I make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off and blue to can increase
performance and give you that extra
confidence you may be looking for blue
to calm blue like the color blue is the
first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue troop repairs and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
comm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show